mira no soy abogada entonces si tiene
futuro no legal no puedo decir pero
puedo decir que para mí bueno admiro
mucho a ella sí creo que tiene una gran
importancia cultural ellas están
denunciando el escándalo de dejar un
abusador y seguir con sus abusos durante
tanto tiempo la verdad es que las
autoridades tanto en los eeuu como en
otros países no toman en serio la
violencia hacia las mujeres y así los
niños vemos eso en el caso de la renacer
y también también vemos eso en los casos
de los sacerdotes por todo el mundo que
muchas veces hacen sus abusos durante
décadas
yo creo que sí que va a tener un gran
impacto este caso bueno ustedes si bien
nos aclaraba no no es abogada pero
quisiera preguntarle por qué es
importante mantener vigentes las
denuncias de abusos
porque
los agentes del fbi que básicamente
ignoraron
las acusaciones y no
no se nos dieron el peso debido a la
importancia de un médico abusar
repetidamente a docenas de jóvenes
atletas
no debían de ser impunes no debían de
poder seguir
como si no fuera nada y estos jóvenes no
han recibido
lo suficiente básicamente del sistema yo
creo que su motivo no es tanto económico
sino dar presión a estas gentes de
investigar como debe ser de tomar en
serio los abusos hacia las mujeres y
hacia los jóvenes y yo estoy agradecida
personalmente yo creo que esta es como
una noticia por
agentes policiales por el mundo que
tienen que tomar en serio esos abusos
están sentando cree usted unas buenas
bases para influir no sólo en lo que
sucede en eeuu sino a lo largo del mundo
no en lo que es la violencia contra las
mujeres yo creo que hemos visto en el
movimiento del del mito a ninguna más
ninguno menos
manifestaciones sobre el femicidio sobre
violencia sexual sobre violencia
doméstica de que es un movimiento
mundial entonces más de 90 mujeres han
demandando al fbi hacer el trabajo que
debía de hacer si no pagar las
consecuencias yo creo que sí que va a
tener un eco mundial